[Music]
a little over three years ago i saw a
video on youtube of a cell dying and i
loved it so much that i reached out to
the person who posted that video his
name was james and in that email i wrote
the following
i've always wanted to do a microscopy
show we've just lacked the expertise you
have something pretty special on your
hands an obvious passion talent and the
right equipment i'm interested and
possibly partnering with you on a
channel i'm thinking of something that
has a real chill look and feel something
that celebrates the beauty of that world
but gives people a chance to relax while
also learning
james agreed
it is unusual for an idea to go from
inception to execution with so little
modification
that first pitch is pretty much what
this channel continues to be today aside
from the original idea for the name of
the channel which was
the germ house
through the years there have been some
very exciting developments james has
been able to upgrade his microscope
multiple times we've been able to share
marine life as well as fresh water we've
captured some truly exceptional moments
and even we think discovered entirely
new species but also how i have thought
about microscopy has changed before i
found james's footage i wanted to make
microscopy content but i thought i
couldn't there were so many microscopes
and so many different words i didn't
know i honestly didn't really know what
a silly it was
as i watched more and more footage and
narrated more and more episodes i
started to understand that this isn't
something that's just for experts
obviously i will never be as
accomplished as james but after getting
my own micro cosmos microscope as part
of our kickstarter i found that this was
an extremely
fulfilling and also fairly accessible
hobby
spending time in my neighborhood
understanding my local microcosmos has
been very exciting the changing ecology
of the seasons my first tardigrade
sighting and just the variety of life at
different depths of water and sediment
the micro cosmos microscope changed my
whole outlook on this channel
it's not just a project that tells
people about their world
we hope
it is an invitation into that world
there are so many more people with
telescopes than with microscopes but no
offense to all those backyard
astronomers out there there is a lot
more to see looking down than looking up
and we want to help more people start
their own journeys so they can explore
the unseen world that surrounds them so
that is why we launched the micro cosmos
microscope kickstarter in early 2021 and
we made sure to offer a high quality
introductory microscope with a cell
phone adapter so that everybody could
document their own journeys and the
people who supported that kickstarter
have enabled the next step we are taking
today the launch of microcosmos dot
store
this new store exists to welcome folks
on their own journeys right now we've
got a fairly limited number of micro
cosmos microscopes available but we will
be restocking them later on this year so
get them while they're hot we'll also be
increasing the number of microscopy
tools and accessories we offer
right now along with the microscope you
can get things like reinberg filters
oblique illumination filters slides and
coverslips our microscopy field guide
and a microcosmos microfiber cleaning
cloth we have even developed a series of
instructional videos explaining how to
get started with both the equipment and
sampling your local micro cosmos
and of course we've got some cool stuff
that you can get to represent your
appreciation for the micro cosmos you
can download our soundtrack to listen to
while you search your slides or cozy up
in our new lacrimaria socks we've also
got a glow-in-the-dark tardigrade pin a
very cool and clever sweatshirt and this
new hydra t-shirt is just fantastic
and finally possibly my favorite thing
is this poster with art by one of
james's mentors that will help you
identify the microbes that you find in
your samples it has over a hundred
species on it and also it just looks
very cool
in case this isn't clear to you we
really have been going on a journey
together and i'm not just saying words
when i say thank you for coming on it
with us i am so grateful to have had
this richness added to my life
a new and deep appreciation for
something that was just a few short
years ago the unseen world that
surrounds me
now before we go we'd also like to thank
each and every one of our patreon
patrons without whom this channel and
this store could not exist so we are so
grateful for all of you who have decided
to sign up over at patreon.com
journey2micro if you would like to see
more from our master of microscopes
james weiss check him out at jam and
germs on instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's probably a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]